welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of ms
marvel episode 4 which takes kamala to
pakistan for even more boys to fight
over her you get yours kamala from
hidden realms to ant-man murals and urdu
let's break down this episode frame by
brain for all the details you missed
because there is so much to explain here
the best way to support any rockstars is
by checking out our ms marvel inspired
cosmic daydream shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com where you'll get the
added option to write in a custom shout
out for our after shows also a reminder
we'll be in austin this weekend at rtx
hit us up on twitter for details onto
the episode unlike previous episodes
this opening previously on segment
switches to urdu as much of the visible
text in this episode does including the
closing credits as this series
transitions from jersey city to karachi
pakistan over the marvel fanfare the
music is summer nights by reginder
featuring wise child foreshadowing
asana's later description of the night
she was separated from aisha at the
train station it was the middle of
partition
and it was a hot summer night a tragic
summer night kamala revisits in the
episode's final scene the opening shot
shows outside of the plane window a
cloud looming over the city of karachi
with the wing light shining through and
for a second it evokes the existential
threat facing this dimensional plane
revealed later this episode the veil of
noir collapsing in the alternate realm
of light flooding this one it has been
some time since kamala ruined amir's
wedding and she hasn't heard from her
friend nakia she scrolls through her
text quickly but they read i'm so sorry
please answer me i'll explain everything
hopefully you're all okay and no one is
hurt i wish things could go back to
normal and like they were before please
say something anything i don't know why
i thought i could be a hero it's so much
harder than i thought i don't know what
else to say or how to fix this i'm
really sorry please just let me know
you're okay though i don't know why
kamala expected new text to come in
she's been on an international flight
and the plane isn't really low enough to
get a sell signal unless she's using the
in-flight wi-fi but even then since it's
international flight wouldn't she have
to switch her sim card i don't know she
might just be doing that thing where
she's reviewing a bunch of texts that
she sent right before the flight
departed and now as the flight is
landing she's waiting for a new signal
panicking waiting for what that response
will be because i always do this i'm
always wondering am i fired am i fired
am i fired does everyone hate me does
everyone hate me did a trailer drop mid
flight these are anxiety poison i like
how hesitant to send people to start to
stand up to get stuff out of the
overhead sit down
i mean this is case on any flight but
especially international flights just a
very common and weird thing for
passengers to do kamala arrives at the
karachi airport blinded by the light of
the excitement around her we see a
returning champion cricket team
celebrating and then she is showered
with red flower petals recalling her
fantasy of cameron in episode 2 and
she's greeted by her cousins and her
nani sana they pass by a mural of
muhammad ali jinnah the founder of
pakistan
and they pass under this sign karachi
the city of lights another hint of the
hidden realm threatening this plane the
nor dimension nor of course minion light
this is literally the city of lights
about to become a city of even more
light now they used a number of
establishing shots from the city of
karachi but all the exterior shots with
the actors were shot on lots in thailand
then mixed into the opening ms marvel
titles are a number of them written in
urdu and i like how one of these miss
marvel logos is scorched into a
delicious piece of naan they arrive at
sana's home where they meet the
wonderful dog of magnum who needs to
immediately become best friends with
lucky kamala finds sana's study painting
room where on the walls are newspaper
clippings related to the partition one
mentions lord mountbatten addressing the
pakistan constituent assembly lord
mountbatten was a royal navy commander
and member of the british royal family
who oversaw the partition and was
assassinated by the ira in 1979 a
fascinating episode of the crown where
he's played by charles dance tywin
lannister you know the show the crown
where we all have to like pretend we
care about the winds of the royal family
oh my horse doesn't like me meanwhile
what are we doing to imperialize the
world never mind that my cousin is
flirting with me this is one of the many
reasons i like this show we're telling
stories about you know everyone else in
the world one of sana's art pieces shows
figures in shadow walking across a
purple hued cosmic backdrop looking a
lot like the nor realm that kamala
briefly dropped into when she first
clipped on that bengal in episode 1 and
we see a bird's eye view of in this
episode after all sana does see those
same trained visions these are likely
visions in her dreams too kamala and
sauna chat about their background
am i
ajin
of course
at least that is what my father told me
how are you so casual about this i i
don't see what the whole verse is about
it's just genetics
a bit of a pun there
genetics sana explains that the term gin
is really just a name given to them and
tells her again that story about how a
trail of stars saved her on the night of
the partition by reuniting her with her
father at that chaotic train station
until a trail of stars appeared
and took me right back into his arms on
the train and i am assuming that this
trail of stars will be revealed to
either be aisha maybe using her nor
projections to save her or perhaps the
carrier of the other bengal like a cree
warrior maybe a forebearer to captain
marvel or maybe one of the cree created
in humans like black bolt or maximus i'm
still holding on to hope that inhumans
might come up in the show kamala says
that she can't figure out this puzzle
and keeps breaking it even more yet sana
advises if you have lived like i have
lost what i have
you learn to find beauty in the pieces
interesting wisdom for this era that
we're now entering in the mcu that a
broken fractured multiverse is more
beautiful than one that makes sense
kamala flashes back to the battle at the
wedding hall in episode 3 including this
one shot of adam striking her f this guy
but notice how light flashes on him so
we are seeing him from kamala's point of
view as her nor light activated to
shield her she has this vision as the
portrait of aisha rests beside her on
the pillow showing how she's really
sharing this dream with her great
grandmother oh sorry i didn't realize
you were in here with someone yeah her
cousin is joking about her sloth baby
napping pillow but kamala was with
someone here aisha kamal and the rest
have to eat on the patio because of the
boat club's no jeans policy or is it a
no genie policy i'm sorry i will leave i
am so sorry
[Music]
as they tour the city kamala wears her
new jersey avenger con shirt that she
got at the convention back at episode
one her cousin says on is this not
exotic enough for the abcd's instagram
you know american born confused i know
what it means yes this is a term used by
south asian people to refer to second
and third generation americans of their
same ethnicity might also remind you of
the slang abc or american born chinese
which showed up in crazy rage asians in
one of the texts and might also be the
reference in the abc chinese restaurant
in this episode but i feel like none of
this is for me to discuss i am sorry i
love you i'm just trying to learn and
i'll shut up now at the polaroid stand
there is a qr code one of these of
course appears in every episode and this
week when you scan it it takes you to ms
marvel number 12 from 2015. you can read
this comic for free here this is when
kamala travels to karachi and runs into
the red dagger and i love the joke here
this is a polaroid stand the meta joke
is for us to literally take a picture
with our phones of this stand kamala
visits the train station and checks out
a historic section that's under
renovation and there's a mural of
ant-man resizing from small to large and
he's speaking a word bubble in urdu
which translates to as powerful as an
ant and then there's a text box you can
start small and still be larger than
life karachi avengers series part four
telling us that this is part of a series
i love it the artist is sarah hussein
after adrian alfona adrian alfono was
the artist of the g willow wilson ms
marvel series and his name also appeared
as the school founder back in episode
one and we gotta point out that this is
the latest of many ant-man references on
this series which might just be because
ant-man is a low-stakes comedic avenger
that kamala in the show references more
than the others to balance out all the
nods to captain marvel and iron man also
he is one of the more public-facing
avengers since it was his podcast that
she listened to to learn about what
happened in any game also hawkeye did
have a weird amount of ant-man nods that
didn't really amount to anything but it
is just a reminder that people on the
street level of the mcu are all about
ant-man and pemtech and i really hope
that we do see a version of kamala's
powers where she can truly resize the
way ant-man can she's then attacked by
the red badger kareem also from this run
of the comics vigilante from karachi who
actually ends up moving to jersey city
he asks her do all my stamina can have
superpowers well how do you know i'm not
canadian yeah i met a joke here iman
vilani is canadian might be why she's so
dang likeable kamala uses her
nor fist to punch kareem and he releases
a series of nor darts that if you look
closely actually go into ant-man's legs
on that mural kamala catches a dagger in
her hand the way bucky can catch knives
but uh she's definitely not as good at
throwing it
they end up referencing ninja turtles
and danky kang and they fight to a draw
come with me if you want to live what
just kidding i've always wanted to say
that yes the famous line from the
terminator but i like how kamala doesn't
get the reference why because
terminators are moving for dance just
kidding it's a movie for everyone
everyone should watch it really just t2
judgement day no joke top five move for
me i love that movie and i'm not even a
dad but i want to be one
as i enter the hideout kamala asks red
daggers
what are you enough pakistani boy band
another boy band reference in the mcu
the avengers broke up we're toast like a
band like like the beatles the avengers
yeah that's great thank you what is that
well you don't have the avengers is that
a band are you in a band fantastic board
didn't you guys chart in the 60s she
meets waleed played by the amazing actor
faron akhtar who actually starred in the
movie the sky is pink whose song played
in the credits of last episode he
explains here the clandestines are not
like the gin you've heard about stories
on religious texts i mean if thor landed
in the himalayan mountains he too would
have been called a gin yes waleed is
alluding to the concept that thor and
other asgardians only have their norse
identities because of where on earth
they arrived in reality thor is an
extraterrestrial and the clandestines
are interdimensional it's just the human
societies who call them jinn jin really
come from pre-islamic folklore far
pre-dating the hundred years that the
clandestines have been here now big
announcement the god butcher world tour
is here and epic hero shop has the merch
for it and what's more epic than the
necker sword skewering thor's head done
up in an 80s heavy metal style nothing
none more epic on the back it's got
tourist stops that include realms gore
visited in the comics and places he
might hit in the movie get it on a
t-shirt or a poster or both so you can
match your wall and if you're worried
about your head feeling left out get
thor's strongest avengers hat while
supplies last grab these designs and
mark your calendars because on july 7th
we are dropping a new latest obsession
and of course don't forget about the ms
marvel collection they got shoes and
stickers notebooks and bomber jackets
shop these designs and more at
epicheroshop.com walid continues
the clandestines and aisha are from
another
[Music]
this map shows you how our two worlds
coexist whoa a lot to unpack here so
notice how walid twists a knob to show
the superimposition of another realm map
hovering over our world map if you were
to twist that knob a bit more who knows
we might see a different realm map now
these lines do not adhere to any
geography topography or tectonic
features of our planet or align to
really any places of interest in the mcu
like wakanda or new asgard and that is
accounting for if you were to align from
while leads vantage point but he uses
the term realm which is different from
how universe has been used in the mcu so
to be clear here universe refers to
parallel realities within a multiverse
each of which are doppelgangers of our
world with variants of ourselves living
in it the 616 universe the 838 universe
the variants we saw in what if the
alternate manhattans that strange in
america crashed through because notice
even the honeycomb world the tube world
the bone world were still alternate
urban manhattans just made of different
things so set that aside while we
explain what realms are realms refer to
surrealist ethereal buffer zones between
universes where unknown beings live so
you got the nord dimension talo from
chongqi and the realms beyond where the
dweller and darkness originated the dark
dimension the quantum realm the
ancestral plane the duat underworld
valhalla the gap junction the mirror
dimension the astral plane the shadow
realm from thor love and thunder
thanos's soul realm all of these seem to
be accessed either via death or through
physical waypoints that are hidden in
our reality and a lot of the realms i
just mentioned definitely have spiritual
connotations and they seem to be
constant to all of the universes that i
mentioned in the multiverse like there
might be only one quantum realm that is
shared by all these universes i think
like i'm mostly getting that from agents
of shield in which they use the quantum
realm to bridge different timelines but
this also seemed to be the case in
multiverse of madness where clia took
strange to the dark mission to fix an
incursion between universes suggesting
that the dark dimensions a kind of
neutral zone where they could look at
two distinct universes independent of
any one of them then we see another
device showing the nord dimension there
are many dimensions around us that we
cannot see
this is just one of them
what is this aisha's home it's connected
to our world but hid
behind the whale of noor that separates
our world from us yes more to unpack the
veil of nor is this realm's waypoint
like the waterfall that separated earth
from tallow and chongqi and the dragon
scale gate that separated talo from the
realms beyond where the soul sucker
comes from so this nor realm is implied
to exist on a dimensional plane on top
of our realm similar to how the mirror
dimension and the astral plane the
shadow realm exist all around us just
unseen this might be why beings like the
jackals and moon knight and gargantos
were initially invisible the nora realms
surrealist columns tower high above the
high rises of karachi and it glows the
same color of kamala's nor light this is
definitely the realm that she briefly
fell into back in episode 1. also look
closely on the far end of the nor realm
is a tree which seems very important
when t'challa entered the ancestral
plain he saw his panther spirit
ancestors in a tree to me this indicates
that the nord dimension also has a
spiritual essence to it also i like how
this realm assembles in this device via
gray sands or grains reminding us of the
granular vibranium that the wakandans
use to depict their origins but then
walid and kareem warn nur is the energy
source of that realm the veil the
clandestines
even your powers are made of it if the
clandestines use the bangle to tear down
the veil
they'll unleash their world onto us
until there's nothing left of it
yeah this sounds a lot like the
incursions we heard about in doctor
strange in the multiverse madness when
one universe collides with another
universe an incursion occurs when the
boundary between two universes erodes
and they collide
destroying one or both
entirely so i don't know i may be wrong
about there being a difference between
universe and realm and the way marvel
studios defines these terms and maybe
this realm incursion is meant to be the
same thing as a universe incursion but i
don't know for now i think universes and
realms are different enough to assume
that they are different categories of
dimensional terrains and both are just
affected by the same crisis so if we
imagine each universe to be its own
house in a row of cookie-cutter model
homes in a suburban street realms would
be the yards the driveways the sidewalks
the streets the ponds the aquifers the
gas lines the avocado trees the
doghouses between all these houses and
so for two houses to collide with each
other there must be some kind of flood
or earthquake that also causes the yards
the gas lines the avocado trees to smash
into those houses first those trees and
turf and water all amounting to what a
realm is a buffer zone in between the
houses and we may have already seen some
realm incursions existing in the mcu
that could explain what these
supernatural things are things like the
invisible jackals things like vampires
all these supernatural entities actually
coming from realms not other universes
and this earthquake in this extended
metaphor could be a series of smaller
tremors caused by several different
disruptors like sylvia and loki and
peter parker doctor strange wanda
maximoff all of them leading to one big
earthquake causing it all to collide
realms and universes i don't know i
could be dead wrong about all that
that's just where my head is at right
now and in this moment waleed eyes the
bengal i haven't seen that before
in all the years and everything i've
heard about that bangle there was no
mention of an inscription
it says what you seek is seeking you so
since walid can read this and the myths
never mentioned in the description i
think this was added later by aisha a
message that the trail of stars being
sought by sana and now by kamala is some
kind of chain of extraterrestrials cree
or inhumans seeking them i assuming the
ones seeking them are the same entities
being summoned by the beacon in the ten
rings and this inscription is a warning
then we visit the dodc supermax prison
which is the same facility we see in the
she-hulk trailer meaning the abomination
emil blonsky is also being kept in this
place further confirmation of the
authorities facing kamala in this series
is the same agency jen walters will deal
with we speculated this could be the
cube the super villain containment
prison in the nevada desert originally a
shield black site designed for
gamma-radiated inmates later becoming
the home base of the thunderbolts notice
how this structure's angular
architecture does look like a
deconstructed or exploded cube the
clandestines break free cameron getting
hit with the blast of one of the dodc's
sonic cannons the same ones made from
the starktex shrunken down versions of
his hulk repulsor that he installed on
war machine and oshma's weapon looks
like a maduvu used in a tamil martial
art it's made of deer horns but in this
case it looks like it's made of
something different because we see it
melting a lock so apparently her weapon
at least can super heat back in pakistan
sana tells kamala the confusion between
her pakistani and indian roots there is
a border marked with blood and pain yeah
it's my favorite detail this episode
when it comes to the thematic connection
between sana's border and the border of
the veil of nor sana explains how all
political borders are a bit arbitrary
and leave us divided this episode
explains how the political map we
thought we knew of this planet is
actually pretty irrelevant when you
superimpose the maps of other realms
over this one kamala joins kareem's
friends around a bonfire as this guy
sings an urdu cover of didi by cheb
khalid meanwhile son and iba reconnect
over going through milk toffees boxes
remember sana sent kamala the bengal in
one of these boxes in episode one and
after santa maniba are finally honest
with each other's episode the trauma
begins to heal as the next generation of
women bond over eating these milk
toffees i just love the visual
storytelling of this prop here we'll
leave gives kamala some fabric to wear
showing how she is piecing together her
own costume but the clandestine's attack
leading to a chase in the streets of
karachi now they referenced terminator
earlier i just can't help but see a
parallel in the good guys on the small
rickshaw versus the clandestines
pursuing on the larger truck and the
terminator john connor and t2 on the
motorcycle fleeing the t-1000 on the
semi kamala spots a family of four way
insanely trying to pile on a motorcycle
the babies should not be on that kamala
forms a nor ramp that rolls the truck
and kamala ends up back behind the wheel
a callback to her driving test in
episode one and just like then she
floors it in reverse initially walid
kills saleem and then najib stabs waleed
and kareem kills adam and najma stabs
the bengal sending kamala through this
rift now these tears and the fabric of
reality look a lot like the slices that
khlea made in the multiverse of
madison's post-credits scene when she
tore an opening back to the dark
dimension which makes me think that
kamala is not going back in time here
who's really going into the nord
dimension the light dimension versus the
dark dimension and this is really a
memory that she's going into of course
she finds herself back on that hot
summer night at the train station that
sana referred to when the families were
forced to separate during the partition
it is heartbreaking to end this episode
here but i'm not sure if kamala is truly
being transported back in time like you
could totally read this as kahala is
going to be the one to create the trail
of stars she's going to save her own
grandmother it's going to be
self-fulfilling time loop harry potter
saving himself another version of who's
the jewel from game of thrones i mean i
don't know that might be the case i'm
just leaning towards this being a memory
contained within the bengal because as
kamala walks around no one really looks
at her or reacts to her there's just one
guy who kind of steps around her when
she turns to climb the train car and
krietek is known for being intertwined
with memory from project tahiti and
agents of shield warping certain aspects
of coulson's memory to carol danvers
having implanted memories causing her to
see scrolls as the enemy so i think
kamala is on a similar journey of
self-discovery that carol was on
similarly witnessing this memory but
from the point of view of her
grandmother or her great-grandmother she
may be walking in one of their shoes in
this moment kamala does see a woman with
her daughter but this woman is credited
as a different actress than the actress
who plays aisha also remember aisha was
separated from sana in this moment sana
would have been with her dad and then
separated from her dad as well and then
the trail of stars brought her back to
her dad i assume next episode we will
see exactly what that trail of stars was
whatever cosmic source is seeking the
bangle again could be the cree or their
terran experiments the inhumans folks
like black bolt or maximus for now at
least folks the inhumans are still on
the table in the final shot does show
kamala being enveloped in steam from the
steam engine as haze surrounds the
masses a visual non-detergent mist we
may have missed the mist and again
something i love about the closing
credits the locales have been all
swapped from jersey city to karachi on
the green traffic light from brad
winterbomb instead of kamala's bolt logo
on the light it is the pakistani flag
another thing they swapped out the art
of kamala sitting on the swing now hangs
from the crescent and the star of the
pakistani flag what was the title this
episode seen red and like doctor strange
kamala was forced to go on red in this
case go on that smoke show kareem that's
everything i spot in this episode you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at
us follow me rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thank you so much
for watching bye
[Music]
you